greek yogurt has been around for a while
uh it's not a new thing but in the early
uh 2010s it kind of had this revival and
chobani did play a part in it in you
know bringing back the greek yogurt
in 2020 the total yogurt category which
consists of
everything including greek yogurt saw
its sales increase by 4.4
from 2019 and total greek yogurt dollar
sales
went up for the same period by eight
percent
and that's huge and chobani you know
is a smaller business in terms of
you know its revenue and its sales if
you think about
its competition like general mills which
is you know
a larger corporation than it is i think
there's definitely
uh room for chobani uh to grow
especially when the sales
are going up and people are going back
to greek yogurt again hamdi ulkaya is
the billionaire ceo
of chobani which is mostly known for its
yogurts
um but it actually does a bunch of other
products as well
including in non-dairy and in 2020 the
company's revenues were
1.5 billion dollars so
hamdi has been on our billionaires list
uh for a while now
he appeared on our list in 2013 and he's
worth two billion dollars he's one of
the richest turkish people
uh in the world although he is based
in the us he's a turkish citizen
when i started chobani i started from an
old factory
that was there for almost 100 years you
know when i
started this i studied for a reason is
that simple
reason was why do i have to travel
a big city and go to a specialty store
to get a cup of yogurt that is good
why does it have to be all full of
sugars preservatives and
all the stuff that is in there it kind
of made me angry because when i grow up
where you grow up it didn't matter if
you were poor or rich
or if you lived in a city or a village
or a town
a cup of yogurt a good tomato a
pomegranate a little bit of honey
you know milk or whatever those
essential things
were simple they were wholesome they
were delicious
were nice um and it just
didn't make any sense to me um so when i
started it
i started with something that was
missing which is yoga which i missed a
lot
which i grew up a lot but it wasn't
about yogurt it was actually the food
hamdi ulukaya he has a pretty
interesting story so he's an immigrant
he grew up in a nomadic
community in eastern turkey a very
mountainous region
and he you know was exposed to
the business of dairy uh very early on
in his life
and he lived in turkey for a while and
then he decided to come to the us
and study here and what's interesting
about him is that he was studying
in upstate new york where he ran into
a empty plant he applied for small
business loan with the us government
and he was able to get that loan and
vitalize
that plant which you know ended up being
uh chobani nobody had the blueprint
even though nobody had done this before
in this level
even though resources were extremely
limited even though
everything was against us that odds are
being successful was very very minimal
but those conditions those qualities
of human spirit working together you
know
living being optimistic um you know
getting each other's back
and and trying everything you could um
came to work and where we made something
that has never been done before
we turned that plant that's old factory
into one of the largest factory in the
country
he's also active in philanthropy uh you
know
he has done work to help syrian refugees
in
greece and it's very important
to have also an immigrant ceo
uh you know we see a lot of those in
silicon valley
and you know you think about the google
co-founders and
you know the uber co-founders and all
those people but at the end of the day
i think it's also important to see that
you know immigrants do great work
even outside of tech and sometimes
that's just food because
you know they have the great recipe from
home he has been trying to do
some philanthropic work on the side to
kind of
match what appears to be the values of
the company as well
we know that right now a majority of
millennials
actually really want the values of the
companies
that they buy from to align with their
own values
over 50 to 70 percent of the farm
workers
whether in europe new york whether in
idaho or any land in between
are undocumented uh immigrants
so basically they have no rights right
but how they get paid what's the
conditions that they live in
what kind of safety measures that they
have
uh it's it's basically unknown so we
said
what can we do to
have farmers to open the door have
like organization fair trade who has
been doing work like this all around the
globe
chocolate farmers coconut farmers
coffee farmers of some kind of
humane standards that is being
implemented
and observed and checked and
communicated to consumers and saying
these are the people are doing things
right our goal was
to transform this disrupt and change
all the food making in the country